hi there Steve coffin here so today I
want to answer a question that I get all
the time in a little more detail than I
have been able to do question is how
many languages do you speak so I'm going
to go through my languages and how well
I think I speak them and then as an
experiment I'm gonna speak a bit of
Russian towards the end I say an
experiment because I don't know how how
I'm going to do because I basically
haven't done anything in Russian for
literally years so my languages
obviously English that speak the best
followed by French and I think that my
French I don't know what qualifies as C
2 but that would be the language that I
would put forward where I am closest to
C 2 where I'm so proficient that I can
read literature understand movies I I
mean for three years I studied there I
wrote my exams in French I had oral
exams in French I mean it's it's the
language that I that I control the best
all right so that's number two number
three is Japanese where I lived for nine
years and I used it in business all the
time I spent a lot of time initially you
know listening and reading and mensis
before I got a hold of some NHK tapes on
the history of a show here in which I
listened to over and over and over again
did a lot of reading mostly using
textbooks that I was able to find where
they had a vocabulary list behind each
lesson and there were some very advanced
readers of Japanese literature history
paucity with word lists and so I did a
lot of work with Japanese but I lived
there for nine years and just had so
many business meetings lengthy
discussions lengthy negotiations lengthy
conversations about everything history
philosophy you name it all in Japanese
so Japanese number three and maybe i'ma
see one in Japanese I don't know a lot
of these things are quite uneven I can't
write by hand
japanese in type on the typewriter my
written japanese would simply be spoken
Japanese put in writing and it's all
it's a messy one there Chinese comes
next Mandarin Chinese because I studied
it full-time and then I was in and out
of China as a Canadian government trade
commissioner I had a lot of interaction
with Chinese people here in Vancouver
I've done a lot of listening to Yong
Chun this is Chinese comic dialogues and
other material that I have in Chinese so
and I probably use Chinese more than any
other language my wife and I were
recently in Greece and Crete with a
Chinese couple we were speaking Chinese
every day in the car visiting museums
having dinner and soap and so on so
Chinese would be number four and number
five would be Spanish and there
basically I had a Spanish Court course
at McGill but didn't really learn that
much but then I was you know when I was
a student in France used to hitchhike in
Spain spend a lot of time traveling and
then more recently my wife and I have
visited Spain so I've spoken Spanish
there and I got very interested in
improving my Spanish so I bought a lot
of books I remember the first Spanish
book that I read from cover to cover was
a book about national identity in Spain
by a basque person something rather el
bosque I don't remember the name but you
know part of my strategy was to read
more and so when you read your first
book in a foreign language to me that's
like a big deal the same when learning
Chinese I read you know what those young
so the rickshaw boy in Chinese so it's
important to read your first full book
in the language and I did that in
Spanish I did a lot of work at linked in
Spanish where you have audio books so
just to improve my vocabulary so those I
consider my top five now we drop off a
little bit and I think probably next
there are two languages that I speak
very fluently
but I have a more limited vocabulary and
that's Swedish and German and but I did
a lot of business in Sweden I spent a
lot of time listening to Swedish
audiobooks Herman Lindquist reading his
books on the history of Sweden did a lot
of business in Sweden have spoken a lot
of Swedish similarly with German I went
through a period back in 1987 where I
scoured secondhand bookstores in
Vancouver to find books with in those
days we didn't have online dictionaries
we didn't have link so I sought out
readers books with little glasses behind
each chapter and I did a lot of
listening listening and reading I found
these wonderful audio cassettes in
German interviews on radio stations
natural German speaking I did a lot of
listening and then ultimately traveled
to Germany many times in the 90s on
business said with my agent in the car
for hours and hours in the Autobahn
which was often blocked so I spoke a lot
of German so German or Swedish would be
next to that 6 & 7 then probably would
be Italian although I haven't really
spoken it a lot but I have listened to
ill Neurath or a the audio book producer
out of Italy and I've listened to it
promises posey listen to pinocchio done
by him I really recommend it by the way
ill not at all ray you can look it up so
I did a lot of work on my Italian I also
once went through a lingual phone thing
in Italian and it's just that it's it's
you know a lot of Spanish sneaks into my
Italian but I have no trouble
understanding communicating but it's not
a slam-dunk like I had to put a lot of
effort into it I've done a lot of
listening to try the radio national
radio broadcast right do a Alioto della
Serra and
so I have put effort into it and it'll
probably it would be number eight then
it would be probably Portuguese there
again it wasn't a slam-dunk
I initially before we had Portuguese it
linked
I used living language went to Portugal
nobody spoke to me Portuguese they just
reverted to English but then we I worked
on a link I had a tutor in Villa resort
in Brazil I listened to hundreds of
hours of Portuguese podcasts RTI photo
Portugal and then when I went back to
Portugal lo and behold I was able to
carry on conversations in Portuguese
again Spanish sneaks into my Portuguese
but that would be inserted number nine
and number ten probably Cantonese
although I need to refresh it a bit but
I can naturally switch into Cantonese so
those would be the top ten now we move
on to eleven which would be Russian and
Russian is part of those languages that
I've learned basically well Portuguese
as well is something that is you know
since the age of sixty but I had a head
start because of Spanish no Russian was
something I decided to study at the age
of sixty because people said you can't
learn Russian if you don't spend a lot
of time with the grammar and I want to
prove wanted to prove them wrong
plus I wanted to read you know Russian
novels in the original so I spent oh you
know four or five years I mean I
remember I started I think in 2006-2007
maybe so more than yeah and the age of
60 and it was a wild beef and I started
with you know beginner material books
that I could find audio stuff at link I
probably went a couple of years before
speaking and fairly quickly I got into
audio books I remember going to Riga
because we were doing business lumber
business in Riga and buying audio books
there and
I remember discovering these wonderful
Soviet era films and I had this
tremendous period of involvement with
Russia and I've excuse me with Russian
and Russian culture and literature and
it was lovely and I'm gonna try to speak
some Russian at the end here but after
Russian then it goes and so the Russian
I can kind of cope although I haven't
spoken very much I visited Russia for 12
days I have spoken
you know perhaps over the years a link
maybe I've know as many as 100 hours
with our tutors but it's it's still not
a language that I have spoken a lot so I
I struggled and especially since now I
haven't done any Russian for I don't
know three four years it's it's it's
gonna be a bit of a struggle but after
Russian I did check and the check is
even more of a struggle but again if I
get in the environment then I'm okay but
difficult to just turn it on the same
with certainly polish Ukrainian better
because I was in Ukraine I was in l'viv
for total of three weeks and speaking a
lot of Ukrainian so I've actually spoken
more Ukrainian much more Ukrainian
within the last few years that Russian
so 11 is Russian 12 in terms of my level
would be Ukrainian then comes Czech slow
like polish slow back again I have a
bunch of stuff in Slovak that I listen
to but it's very similar to check and
probably when I speak out the weather I
go yeah Kaku you know and different
things that change that it's very very
similar then once we get beyond that now
I'm in trouble
Romanian I have I mean are when I listen
to it when I hear it I understand a lot
but to try and speak very difficult
Greek when I was in Greece I managed
quite well and was complement of they're
very polite you know but I have enough
of a base in both Romanian oh I forgot
Korean Korean is a language where I
actually have a large vocabulary and I
can I can speak but I just don't haven't
reached that level of flu attack and
certainly not fluent in Korean but I
understand a lot so I would say that
Korean Romanian Greek our language is
that I need to work on but I have a
sufficient critical mass of vocabulary
and calm
prehension then I can go back to them
and build them up and if I were to go to
their country within a few weeks I would
be quite comfortable and then I have
Arabic at the end
[Music]